- This is gonna be good.
Here we go.
- So, first of all, we can’t even see it.
- I’m going to have to walk up to it.
- Is that the scene from uh...that’s 16 Candles.
That's the last scene in 16 Candles.
- Is it?
- The last scene in 16 Candles was Molly Ringwald.
- Oh, well, we're all really old.
- It's a lot of food.
I mean, we... Oh, I know what it is!
It's a Harold and Kumar.
They're playing SORRY!
- Yes, yes.
- It’s White Castle, White Castle. - Next!
- That is Hereditary.
Oh, no.
Uh, Pulp Fiction?
- Pulp Fiction!
- I got it! I got it!
- SpongeBob
- SpongeBob Square-butt. Wow. Yeah.
- Whoa
- Yeah
- Wow.
- M&M's?
- I don't know.
- Oh, wait.
- It's a 1970s McDonalds.
- Looks like stop-animation.
- But it's a movie, right?
It's like a feature film.
- 1970s McDonalds.
- I don't know. It's this, uh....
- Pass! Pass!
- It's... Mr. Potato Head.
- You know, this is really mean
to do to a bunch of old people.
- Yeah, it really is.
- This is really funny.
- That's the joke?
- Hold on...um...
- Uh oh. Dumb and Dumber.
- Wow. Good job Eugene.
- Yeah, I’d stay up there.
- I was gonna say Star Trek.
- Just stay up there, yeah.
- Oh, Cloudy With
A Chance Of Meatballs!
It's good. It's really good.
- Oh, that’s uh, Good Burger.
- Good Burger.
- Keenan and Kel.
- Tommy Orlando in dawn.
- Oh, Super Size Me.
- Yeah.
- Oh, yeah. Wow.
- Uh, The Simpsons.
- The Simpsons Movie.
- Uhhhh I mean, should we
name movies from the eighties?
[Cross Talk/Debating]
Like, it was a departure. It was a departure from the movie.
- Oh, you know what, Better Off Dead?
- Oh, Better Off Dead.
- I said Better Off Dead did I get it!?
- Yeah! You got it!
- Yes!
- No, that was Eugene!
- I said Better Off Dead!
- That was Eugene, I just yelled it louder.